c'est la cinquième journée de grève
contre le projet de loi travail examiné
à l'assemblée nationale ce jeudi 12 mai
convergence des luttes chômeurs
travailleurs et étudiants unis depuis
plus d'un mois pour la même cause
comme l'ensemble des secteurs
aujourd'hui on est attaqué violemment
conçoit cheminots qu'on travaille dans
d'autres secteurs est aujourd'hui l'un
combat contre loi un travail sape une
occasion de fédérer un peu tous les
mécontentements qui sont en train de
s'exprimer dans tous les secteurs aux
chemins de fer comme ailleurs et cette
manifestation aujourd'hui là on est
l'expression cette loi est celle d'une
toute petite minorité qui l'imposent
contre l'avis de quasiment tout le monde
et que donc ceux qui sont légitimes
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce qu'ils
prétendent représenter la nation comme
ils le disent eux mêmes et ce sont
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont dans la rue
une surveillance suite aux derniers
débordements le dispositif de sécurité a
été extrêmement renforcer une
mobilisation plus faible pendant les
vacances qui reprend aujourd'hui de
l'ampleur même si les étudiants peinent
à mobiliser en raison des périodes
d'examens activement c'est plus
compliqué puisque les lycéens commencent
à rentrer dans une période de bac
les étudiants sans temps partiel donc
effectivement la mobilisation est encore
plus difficile que ces dernières
semaines il a commencé quand même faire
beau ça va aider mais on espère que la
mobilisation ne va pas trop faiblir et
quand pouvoir garder une pression
constante sur le gouvernement
vernement qui a annoncé l' usage du 49-3
pour faire passer le texte en force pour
les manifestants c'est un déni total de
démocratie
il ya eu un débat parlementaire qui
devait avoir lieu ou du coup le
gouvernement s'est rendu compte qu'il
n'avait pas la majorité au sein de ce
parlement pour faire voter la loi et
malheureusement ébats dans un ils ont
choisi de faire un déni de démocratie et
d'utiliser ce 49 3 qui passe outre et
bat tous les débats démocratiques et ça
c'est une chose qui fait que l'on se
mobilise encore plus aujourd'hui la
semaine prochaine d'autres journées de
manifestation devrait avoir lieu selon
les syndicats ce ne serait que le début
d'une longue mobilisation